SPEAKER: All right.
Welcome, everyone, to
the Authors At series.
I'm thrilled to introduce
Jeffrey Gettleman.
He is the East Africa bureau
chief for the New York Times.
He recently won
the Pulitzer Prize
for international reporting
on his work in Africa.
He has covered warlords,
pirates, rebels,
and elephant poachers.
He's traveled
across the continent
several times, using just
about every motive conveyance
from donkey cart and dugout
canoe to a battered tandem
bike.
And he studied
philosophy at Cornell
and earned a master's
of philosophy
from Oxford, where he
was a Marshall Scholar.
He has appeared as a foreign
affairs commentator on BBC,
CNN, NPR, and other networks.
He's also written for "Foreign
Policy," "The New York Review
of Books," "The New York Times,"
"Sunday Magazine," "The New
Republic," and "GQ."
He currently lives
in Nairobi, Kenya
with his wife and two boys.
And we're thrilled to
have him here today.
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN: Thank You.
Thank you, everybody.
I'm just going to put
this down for now.
So let me begin
just by asking so I
know what I'm dealing with.
One person here's
been in East Africa.
Anybody else?
OK.
Let me start at the beginning.
So I grew up in a suburb of
Chicago, Evanston, Illinois,
and after my freshman
year of college,
I found myself on a
trip to East Africa.
And it was kind of a fluke.
I had a friend who knew somebody
who knew somebody else that
was putting together
this trip to drive
from Nairobi to the southern
part of Malawi, which
was about 1,000 miles.
And I asked my
parents, I said, hey,
do you mind if I go on this
trip and go with these guys
to bring these medical
supplies to refugees?
Because that was the
mission of the trip.
And my parents,
unbelievably, said yes.
The leader of our group was
just a year older than me
and was a college dropout.
That part I left out.
And I had this--
this was 1990 and I
was 18, as I said.
And I had this
amazing summer that
was like a left turn in my life
because, for the first time,
I was around people that
had very, very little.
And yet we were driving
through rural Africa
and meeting people who were
literally wearing rags,
living in little houses and
huts with nothing in them.
We'd peek in their
houses and we'd
see some blankets
balled up on the ground.
The kids had no toys.
They made soccer balls
out of plastic bags.
I don't know if you guys
have ever seen this,
but they'll take
discarded plastic bags
and pack them really tight
almost like a snowball
and then put strings around it.
And that was their soccer ball.
And I had never experienced
poverty like that.
I grew up pretty sheltered
in this affluent suburb.
But beyond the poverty
was this spirit,
this warmth, this sense
of being around people
who were very joyful and open
and eager to share and to take
us in.
It gives me a chill
just thinking about it
because they had they had so
little, yet they had so much.
And I came back from
that trip transformed,
thinking, you know, maybe we
have it all wrong in the West.
You know, chasing wealth and
chasing status, and getting
obsessed with material goods.
Because here are people
that have almost nothing,
and they seemed happier than
us and they were welcoming.
And that just made me want to
live and work in East Africa.
But I didn't know how.
I had the where,
but not the what.
And so I then was kind of cast
in confusion because I didn't--
I hadn't-- none of my parents'
friends knew much about Africa,
I didn't know anybody that
was working in Africa.
I had done this
summer experience,
but that didn't really amount
to anything professionally.
So I just kind of thought
deeply about what I could
do in this part of the world.
I also studied Swahili at
Cornell when I came back.
That was one thing
that I did do.
And the first thing I tried is
I thought I'd be an aid worker.
I said, you know what, I'm
going to save the world.
I'm going to be an aid
worker in Ethiopia,
which was like the
poorest country
in the region at the time.
It still is one of
the poorest countries.
It had just come
out of a civil war.
And so I did an internship for
Save the Children in Ethiopia.
And it was a terribly lonely,
discouraging, frustrating
summer.
Just about everything
we did wasn't working.
There was a real
resentment toward us.
You know, we were talking
before about that sort
of savior dynamic.
And that's really
hard to get through
because we were having all these
programs, and a lot of them
made sense.
You know, here's a
more efficient way
to farm your fields.
If you're going to have sex,
you know, wear a condom.
That will cut down on your
chances of getting AIDS.
Here's some materials
for better schools.
But there was-- there
was this resentment
that we kept running
into where people just
felt like we were patronizing
or humiliating them.
Just that dynamic of telling
somebody how to live their life
is problematic.
And that doesn't mean
you should give up on it,
but I felt like as an outsider,
as a white guy in Africa,
you already feel enough
like an outsider.
You already feel very
conspicuous and different.
And this dynamic with
distributing aid just kind of
added to that.
So then I was confused.
Welcome.
We're just getting started.
No sweat.
So then I was really confused.
And what I had
studied in college
was absolutely no
professional help.
On my transcript, you know,
I had Swahili, Indonesian,
sculpture, English literature,
creative writing, history.
I was all over the place.
There's a line in
the book where I
said my college
transcript was like a map
to nowhere drawn by
a blind cartographer.
Because it was like just--
you'd look at it and be like,
what does this kid really
want to do with his life?
But then I got like
an escape rope,
which is I won the scholarship
to go to Oxford, which
basically just bought me like
two years to kind of figure
out what I wanted
to do with my life.
And that's when I
decided that journalism
was a good fit for me.
And journalism was
my ticket back.
That's what I started saying.
I said, you know what?
I'm going to live
and work in Africa.
I'm going to be a
journalist in Africa
and I'm going to do whatever
it takes to get there.
So I started by
applying to newspapers
all across the country.
And this was at
a different time.
Like the newspaper
industry today in 2017
is much different
than it was in 1996.
Actually, when I got
into the business looking
at historical figures
of circulation
for newspapers, like
1996 was like the peak
of American newspapers.
There were papers all over
the country that were growing,
that were hiring, that were
looking for young people.
And I cast like a
wide net, trying
to find anybody
who would hire me.
And I got exactly one job offer.
And that was in a little
redneck town in central Florida,
north of Tampa.
The newspaper was the "St.
Petersburg Times," which
is a good regional newspaper.
But St. Pete was like Manhattan
compared to where I started.
I started in this little
redneck town, population 5,000.
Confederate flags everywhere,
very racist, very violent,
a lot of domestic abuse.
And one of the first
stories I covered
was a scary one
about a man who was
accused of killing a little
girl and disappearing her body.
And I came into the office one
day-- this is all a true story.
It's in my book.
I came in the office one
day and the editor said,
I need you to do an
interview with Willie Crain.
And I said, who's Willie Crain?
Because I had actually--
another piece of my story
is I had a long
distance relationship
with a woman who's now my wife.
We met when we were
in college and we
kept getting jobs in different
places and we never--
it took us years to get
our acts together and get
in the same place.
So I would go visit her on the
weekends in Washington or New
York and then come back to this
little redneck town, which just
intensified the culture shock.
So I came back on this
Monday and the editor says,
I need you to
interview Willie Crain.
And I said, who's Willie Crain?
And he says, well,
there's a girl missing
and Willie Crain is suspected
of kidnapping and killing her.
And what happened was he met
a woman-- this guy Willie
Crain was a crab fisherman, and
he would go out into Tampa Bay
and put these steel crab
traps under the water.
Have you guys ever
seen a crab trap?
Or a buoy that sort of
floats on the water?
And they're these
steel cages that
sit on the bottom of the ocean
and the crabs come in there.
And this was his job, he had
hundreds of these crab traps.
And a few nights before,
he had met a woman who
invited him back to her house.
They were watching TV--
actually the movie
"Titanic"-- in her bedroom.
She said her back
hurt, he offered
to give her some Valium.
He gave her like five times
the normal dose of Valium.
They kept watching the movie.
The woman had a little girl
who was eight years old.
And when she woke up, he was
gone and the girl was gone.
And that's all anybody knew.
And when the woman then
called the police and said,
I just woke up and I had this
guy, Willie, and my daughter's
missing, they ran his name
and they told the woman
that he had gone to prison
for molesting little girls
the exact same age.
And he should have been
in prison for 50 years,
and he got out early because
it was at the time when
the Florida prison system was
very crowded and they were just
kicking people out, and he got
out way before he should've.
So I'm this like
cub reporter who
wants to go to Africa, right?
I'm not trained to
cover the police.
I'm just kind of faking it,
as you do on a first job.
You don't ask a lot of
questions because you talked
your way into the job,
and if you start saying,
well, actually, how
do you do an interview
and what questions
should I ask, the boss
is going to look at you and
be like, well why the hell did
we hire you?
So that's part of the
whole magic, right,
of those first jobs.
It's like you sort of bite off
a lot and really sell yourself,
and then you have to sort
of figure it out on the job.
And there was a lot
of that in this job.
So I got an address
for this guy.
And this is back in the day
when our first resource--
and this is crazy to be
standing in Google saying this--
but our first resource
was a phone book.
A printed-- I know,
it's funny, right?
Printed phone book.
That was the first
thing we would do.
We'd look up somebody's name,
and look for their phone
number and their address.
And then we would sort
of take it from there.
We had these map books that--
you guys remember the
Thomas Guide LA map books?
Does that ring a bell?
So way before GPS and
Google Maps and all that,
you would have these
analog, spiral-bound map
books where they would list
the streets in the back
in alphabetical order.
And so if you had to go to
Cherry Street, you'd look
and it would say, Cherry
Street page 50, A5,
and you'd find-- that's
how we got around.
So I drove up to this guy's--
this guy, Willie's, house.
And he had been denying.
He was on the loose.
He was the prime suspect
because of his background,
but they had no evidence.
This girl had vanished.
The police were looking
in the crab traps,
they were pulling up these
seaweed covered crab traps,
they were looking in his
boat, all around the area
for any trace of this girl.
Nothing.
They didn't find-- nothing.
No evidence whatsoever.
So they couldn't
arrest this guy.
So everybody knew
he was the suspect,
but they had no evidence on him.
So I knock on his door,
and I'm terrified.
I'm like 25 years old,
knocking on the door
of an accused murderer's
house by myself.
It's part of the job.
And he opens the door, and
he looked very agitated.
His hair was really messy
and his clothes looked dirty.
And I was like 25, he
was close to 50, I think.
The strangest thing, though,
is he had these black lines
on his neck that he had
taken a magic marker
and traced these lines on his
neck, like tribal markings
or something.
So he welcomes me
into his house.
He was actually kind of
surprisingly friendly.
And I left one thing out.
I had met his daughter,
and his daughter somehow
trusted me and arranged
for me to go meet the dad.
The daughter was an
adult, maybe 30 something.
And so she had convinced
her dad to talk
to me, because he had refused
to talk to anybody else.
So this is like a big scoop.
I'm talking to this guy, Willie
Crain, who everybody thinks
is this child molester, killer.
And in local news,
these are big stories.
Like this is on the
evening news every night,
it's on the front page
of the local paper.
Everybody wants to know what
happened to the little girl.
There were dozens of
people volunteering,
looking in the crab traps.
It was like a big--
it was like a storm in
Tampa for a few weeks.
You know, what
happened to this girl?
So Willie takes me
into his trailer.
He lives in like a double wide--
you know, what they call like
a double wide mobile home.
Aluminum siding, you know, very
cheaply made, kind of rotting,
sinking into the jungle
almost because this
is a very kind of
lush part of Florida.
We sit down and I
say, Willie, what
are these lines on your neck?
And he's got a knife on
the table next to him.
I kid you not.
He's got his big buck
knife and sharpening stone
right next to him.
And he says, I drew
those lines on my neck
because they're asking
me for a blood sample,
and if they make me
give a blood sample,
I'm going to give them all
the blood they can get.
Meaning he's going
to slit his throat.
And so I'm like this 25-year-old
kid on like a suicide watch
now.
And so I'm nervous,
but I have a job to do.
I'm trying to talk to this
guy and get some information.
And so he sits down and he's
got this big plate of food.
He was eating lunch when
I knocked on the door.
And he's got this big plate
of food, and it's porkchops.
And he's cutting
up these porkchops.
And I'm just trying to keep
the conversation going,
because I don't know.
I'm overwhelmed.
Nobody's ever taught
me how to handle myself
in this situation.
I'm scared, like personally.
You know, that this guy
might do something to me.
I'm thinking he probably
won't, because he's already
under so much suspicion.
That kind of gives
me some safety,
but he could be totally crazy.
Who knows?
And so we're talking, talking.
And finally, I
say, "Willie, looks
like you're pretty hungry."
And he puts down his knife
and fork, and he looks at me.
And he says, "damn
skippy I'm hungry.
This is the first meal I've had
since that little girl died."
Which was a slip-up.
Because he had been denying
that he knew anything about what
happened to that little girl.
He had told the police, "I just
left that house that night.
She was sleeping in bed.
I have no idea what
happened to her.
She maybe ran away.
She's out there somewhere."
And so he's just admitted to
me that he knows she's dead.
And the instant he said that,
the muscles under his eyes
started twitching.
And I just was terrified.
Because I thought, "he did it.
He killed this little girl."
And I'm sitting across from
him, and nobody knows that.
So eventually I
extracted myself safely.
We did a big story on it.
It became a big scoop, because
you know, he made a slip-up.
And I had to call him back.
And I kind of felt bad.
I felt like I sort of
tricked him a little bit.
And as a young reporter, it
wasn't my job to defend him,
but I also felt sort of guilty,
like I'd manipulated him,
I had tricked him into
saying something that
was going to really hurt him.
Or I shouldn't say
hurt, but something
that seemed almost unfair,
like I had ambushed him.
So I called him back up.
I was like, "Willie, what did
you mean by the first meal you
had since that girl died?"
And he made up some
excuse about how, oh well,
everybody was saying she's
dead, so she's got to be dead.
He just dug the hole deeper.
So we ran the story.
It became a big scoop.
And that led to
me getting on a TV
show, that then led to a job
at the Los Angeles Times.
That was my ticket out.
And his case meanwhile went on.
And he was convicted, first
degree murder and kidnapping,
because eventually they did
forensic analysis of all
of his stuff in his trailer, and
they found a pair of underwear
with a drop of blood.
That was the little
girl's blood.
And that's all they
ever found to this day.
And he got convicted
and sentenced to death.
He's on death row in Florida.
And that was my first
taste of a big story,
and a weird, dark, kind
of scary, strange story.
But that began, that
gave me momentum.
And it's like, these
things are so much luck.
Like, maybe everybody
in this room
has the same type
of something that
happened to them at some point
that just turned their career
in a different direction.
Purely kind of luck.
So I worked at the LA Times, and
then September 11th happened.
And that just opened
up the landscape,
because all of a sudden there
was a need for young reporters
to go across the world
looking for information
about terrorism.
So I was sent to Egypt, to
Yemen, to Afghanistan, and then
to Iraq.
And I spent a lot of time
covering the Iraq War.
That was also terrifying
because journalists
are supposed to be
the observers and not
a factor in the equation.
And in Iraq, there was
such deep resentment
towards any American.
There were a few Iraqis
that were initially
excited about the overthrow
of Saddam Hussein,
but that went away
pretty fast, and there
was a huge part of the
population that hated us.
And I was kidnapped by
insurgents in Fallujah.
I was driving down a road.
And the road was supposed
to be clear, and all of us,
we had talked to people that had
traveled on that road earlier
in the day.
And we said, "hey,
is that road OK?
You know, there's some
insurgent areas around there."
And they said, "no, no.
We were just on it.
It's fine."
Which is as best you
can do sometimes.
And we were driving
down the road,
a van cut off the
road in front of us.
And these guys with
masks on their faces
jumped out with guns.
And then all of a
sudden, at the same time,
there was dozens of
other guys with guns,
surrounded us, pulled us out of
the car, held us at gunpoint,
and started asking us
questions, shouting questions.
"Who are you?
Why are you here?
Who sent you?
And most importantly,
where are you from?
Are you American?"
I had an American passport
just a few minutes
before this in my pocket.
And as we were
getting surrounded,
I took it out and handed it to
a female photojournalist who
was sitting next to me, who
stuffed it down her pants
along with her passport.
And so I then went through this
lie for the next several hours,
where I told these
guys I was Greek.
I just thought of
that on the spot,
because Greece was one of
the few Western countries
that was not in Iraq.
France was the other one,
but I don't speak French
and a lot of people
do speak French.
But so many other countries, you
know, England, Australia, New
Zealand, Canada, Italy, they
were all part of this coalition
to overthrow Saddam Hussein.
So if you said you were from any
of those countries, you could--
they wouldn't like that.
So I spent the next several
hours interrogated at gunpoint
with these guys looking at
me, saying the same questions
again.
They kept passing us up to
different people, saying,
"who are you?
What are you doing here?
Where are you from?
Are you American?"
And at the end of the day,
finally, some commander
put us through the
questions again,
and then just said,
"get out of here."
And we drove back to Baghdad.
And it was only when
we got back to Baghdad
that I realized how--
I was so caught up in
the moment of just trying
to save my skin that I didn't
understand the gravity of it.
And it was only at the end
of the whole experience
when all of our staff were lined
up on the lawn of our house
in Baghdad, the Iraqi staff.
And they hugged us, and
they just started bawling.
And it was then that I realized
they thought they were never
going to see us again.
And so this is like the ups
and downs of journalism.
From Iraq, I then
finally got my dream job.
It took much longer than I
ever thought it would take.
It took me 10 years from when
I started, but finally in 2006,
I was sent to Nairobi, Kenya.
Nairobi is a beautiful place.
It's a big city,
one of the biggest
cities in sub-Saharan Africa.
It's very green.
It's right on the equator,
but at 6,000 feet.
So it's got this perfect
climate, where every day
it's warm and
sunny, but it never
gets too hot because
of the altitude.
And there's flowering
trees everywhere,
and lots of little, windy roads,
even in great central Nairobi.
And the job was to
cover East Africa, which
is 12 countries, different
degrees of development
and conflict, and different
issues of poverty,
bad governance, histories
of ethnic tensions,
different in each country.
Each country has
its own dynamic,
and I sometimes get
criticized, and other people
get criticized for talking
about Africa as a country,
or just making these huge
sweeping generalizations
about Africa.
That's valid.
Africa is 54
independent countries.
But many of them do share a
certain very, very obvious
similarities.
And if you look at like the
United Nations Development
statistics, they're all
grouped together, sadly,
at the bottom for
education, lifespan, income,
industrial levels.
There's a lot of similarities
to these countries in Africa.
So I do make some
generalizations,
but I think that's helpful to
understand the bigger picture.
So in East Africa, my job
is to cover the big news.
There's only one of me.
The New York Times
is a big newspaper.
We're still
committed to quality,
on the ground journalism.
But Africa remains a place that
isn't that closely covered,
and we have a correspondent
in South Africa,
a correspondent in West
Africa, and one correspondent
in East Africa.
That was my job.
Is my job.
And I cover like
400 million people
in 12 different countries.
And a lot of the
work is conflict.
Because a lot of these
countries are really badly
governed, and have had long
histories of ethnic conflict
and civil war.
Almost every one.
Kenya is one of the exceptions.
And my first year there,
there was a bungled election
where there was suspicion
that the government had rigged
the election to stay
in power, which it's
pretty obvious that they did.
And the country blew up
in this spasm of violence.
And all around us,
even in Nairobi,
people were killing each
other based on ethnic lines.
There were fires in the street.
I could stand on my porch and
smell burning tires at night.
Even a place like Kenya
that's got so much promise
was very quickly upended
by the same problem
that a lot of African
countries have,
which is these tensions
between ethnic groups.
And this goes back.
I don't want to lecture anybody
for something you already
may know, but this goes back
to the history of colonialism,
that the colonial
powers took these spaces
on the African map, and they
said, "today you're Kenyan.
The guy crossed that
line, he's Tanzanian.
This person is Ugandan.
That person is Sudanese."
Even if they were in
the same ethnic group,
even if they had traded and
coexisted together for as long
as anybody could
remember, all of a sudden,
there were these new
nation states created
that were supposed to have
their own senses of identity.
And that sense of
identity is pretty
weak in a lot of these places.
People have a stronger
sense of their ethnic group.
So on the streets of Kenya,
I can walk out of my house
and hear five different
languages being spoken.
Because people will
speak their tribal tongue
before they'll speak
the national language,
which is Swahili or English.
So over the years, I've
struggled because part of me
wants to honor what brought me
to Africa in the first place,
which was this sense
of warmth and the sense
that people who had so little
are really open hearted
and in a way have better
values than we have,
that they're more
connected to each other.
You can even see it
like in hand-shakes.
Like when Kenyans shake hands,
they come up to somebody,
they shake hands,
and they'll still
stand there going
like this, holding
hands for several minutes
while they're like,
"hey, how's it going?
Haven't seen you for a while.
How are your kids?"
And they're still holding hands.
It's not like a quick
handshake and a retreat.
And that's just a symbol of
how connected people are,
like physically connected,
spiritually connected.
And I love that.
That's a big reason why I
have been there for so long.
The job I'm in is typically
a three to five year job,
and I've been there 11 years.
But at the same
time, there's a lot
of conflict in this
part of the world.
These countries are
poorly governed.
South Sudan, have you guys
been following the news at all?
Or does that just not
conjure up anything specific
when I say South Sudan?
Yeah.
So South Sudan is an
interesting story.
It's the world's newest country.
The South Sudanese
fought for decades
to get their own country.
They felt like they were being
oppressed by the Arabs who
are in control in the
north of the country,
and they started this
guerrilla war in the '50s,
and fought, and fought,
with different
countries helping one
side or the other for their
own strategic interests.
And finally, in 2011, they
won their independence,
in big part because the United
States shook a finger at Sudan
and said, "you've got to give
these guys their independence."
We gave them a lot of money,
the South Sudanese, billions
of dollars from
American taxpayers
for a relatively small country
of about 10 million people,
very underdeveloped.
And there was a
couple of years there
was there was a lot of
pride and joy in the fact
that they were an
independent country.
And then in 2013, one of the
worst civil wars in Africa
in recent years erupted.
And the two leading ethnic
groups in South Sudan
began fighting for who was
going to control the country.
And it was like a fuse that
ripped across the country
and just started igniting
fighting everywhere.
And it wasn't just like men
on men shooting each other.
It was soldiers going into areas
of the opposite ethnic group,
raping women, killing
kids, burning down houses.
This kind of
complete destruction
is the way war is fought.
The same thing had
happened in Darfur earlier.
That was one of
my first stories.
It's this very brutal
form of warfare,
where there's no battle,
there's no battlefields,
there's no lines.
It's about making the
other side suffer,
and just venting all
your anger and resentment
towards the other.
And so South Sudan,
today, is a mess.
It's totally
paralyzed in conflict.
There's now a famine,
because people need food,
and they have been blocked
off by the fighting.
And the government and the
rebels are hijacking aid trucks
and not letting any aid in.
And there's been a
drought in East Africa.
So some of this has ecological
or environmental causes.
So there are
droughts everywhere.
Like, California's
had a bad drought.
But in Africa, if you
have a bad drought
and you have a conflict, drought
plus conflict equals famine.
Because all of a sudden,
these people, they need help.
And there's no way to
get the food in when
people are blowing up the road.
You can do some
airdrops with airplanes,
but there were even
some UN planes that
were shot at by the rebels.
So there are millions
of people now
that are desperate to
get their next meal.
Like this close to starving to
death today, as we sit here.
So in my job, I try
to bring this home.
Like right now, I have you
guys as a captive audience,
doors closed,
you're sitting here,
made the commitment to
come here and listen to me.
But that's not how
it usually works.
I write for a newspaper.
The information goes on the
web or in the print edition.
People are distracted.
They're thinking
of other things.
They're interested
in other things.
And so I have to try to tell
these stories with some urgency
and to make them
interesting or moving
so you continue to read
through this story.
So I was in South Sudan
a couple of months
ago, trying to do this bigger
story about the conflict
and everything I've
sort of told you.
And I'm looking
for some characters
to tell the story,
because in a way,
I'm in the empathy
generation business.
I'm trying to get
people to care.
Because Africa seems so
far away and disconnected.
I care about it.
Other people who've been
there feel the same feelings
that I felt as a young
person, that this
is a special part of the
world that they feel close to
for whatever weird reasons.
But if you've never
set foot there,
you're not going
to feel that way.
And so when I was in
South Sudan, I found--
so just to give you a sense of
my job, I'll plan out a trip.
I'll say, I'm going to
go to a conflict zone
because that's the best
place to set the story.
It's not in the
capital of South Sudan,
where I'm sitting in a nice
hotel, relatively nice hotel.
No, I gotta get
out to the field.
I gotta talk to people who
are suffering, because they're
stories about suffering.
So I'll then make arrangements
to take, let's say,
a UN flight.
Because often in
these countries,
the United Nations is the
only one that has an airline.
There's no other way to travel.
There's no local airline,
and it's too dangerous
to go by road.
If you go by road and
you leave the city,
you could get carjacked
by soldiers, or rebel.
And they'll pull
you out of the car,
kill you, and take your stuff.
It happens all the time.
So just getting to these places
becomes very complicated.
So I go to a place in the
southern part of South Sudan
through a UN flight.
We're staying at a UN camp
that's relatively safe.
We then get cars to go
out to outside the camp.
And we go to these areas where
people have lost everything.
And we're walking
through burned villages.
We're in camps of
displaced people
that are waiting for the
food supplies to come.
And these are like
concentrations of misery.
And so then I get out,
and I introduce myself.
And most people have never--
some places, they haven't
seen many white people.
And they definitely have
never seen a journalist.
The only white people
they've seen are aid workers.
And so immediately
people of surround me,
and they're like, "hey, can
you give some help to me?"
My son is sick, or
my mother is hurt.
And that's a very helpless
feeling that I then feel.
Because I'm just there
to take things from them.
For a higher purpose,
I like to think,
but I don't have a
first aid kit in my car.
I don't have huge
supplies of food.
That's not my role.
And sometimes we
get to these areas
and there are no aid workers.
And we beat the
aid workers there.
And so we show up, and
everybody surrounds our car,
and they think "oh great, save
the children has arrived."
And it's like no, the New
York Times has arrived.
Tell me your story.
So just to use this as an
example, so in this situation
just a couple of months
ago, I found a man
who had just lost his wife.
And he told a very sad story
about how he lived on this farm
with his wife.
They were very poor.
They had a plan, finally, to
go get their first cell phone.
They were going to walk to
town on a Saturday afternoon
and buy a cell phone
for the first time.
Because in a lot of these
places, you'd be surprised.
Almost everybody now has
usually not a smartphone
but a little Nokia phone.
That's pretty common.
You have to be rather poor
these days to not have that.
But these people were like that.
And this man had this plan to
go get a phone with his wife.
Came back to his house
after working in the fields.
House was on fire.
Farm was burned.
His wife was dead on the ground.
Part of an attack, where the
government-- the government,
the government, the same
government that United States
funds and supports--
had gone into this area,
infuriated about rebels,
and just wiped everybody out.
And a lot of times, people
are very stoic, especially
in this part of the
world, where they've
dealt with a lot more
adversity than most of us
will hopefully ever deal
with or probably ever have.
But that became a
basis for my story.
So I thought, "you know what?
People will be able to
connect to this guy."
We all can just imagine
the shock and sorrow
we would feel to come home and
be expecting to see our loved
one and they're dead.
And not just dead from a
disease or some accident,
but somebody killed them.
And so that became a front page
story in the New York Times.
What difference does it make?
I don't know.
I mean, I like to think
it's at least reminding us
of what's happening.
Where we're sitting,
we're in one
of the most successful
nations in the world,
and one of the most successful
parts of that nation,
this part of
northern California,
and one of the most
successful companies ever.
And it's easy to forget
that there's a whole nother
existence out there.
And just to finish
up and then I'd
like to hear some
questions from you guys,
but I just think
that idea of empathy
is the most important thing.
Because if you can start
to of empathize and relate
to people with a totally
different outlook,
and walk of life,
and experience,
then you'll care a little more.
And it's like I tell my kids.
I have a five and
seven-year-old son.
It's really all about sharing.
You tell your kids that.
Share, don't fight.
And it's like that's
all we need to do.
We just need to share some of
our time, some of our feelings,
some of our money, and
it will go a long way.
And it's hard.
Like in South Sudan, we tried.
The United States
government tried
to help this place stand
up on its own two feet.
And it didn't-- it
hasn't worked out.
But that doesn't mean
we should just give up,
because the people like
that guy I wrote about,
they had nothing to
do with the conflict.
They bear no
responsibility whatsoever.
They are victims that were
just living their lives
and got caught up in this
collapsing state that's
eating itself.
And so I just
think like you guys
are in a position where you
work for a powerful company that
is increasingly connected
to the entire world.
That's your mission.
And you just should
think about these people.
Think.
You're sitting in your office,
you're sitting in this room,
and there's some kid in
South Sudan desperate to get
on Google right now.
His phone doesn't work, or
his power just went out,
or his battery died, or
the speeds are really slow
and he can't get
anywhere, or he's on
and he's starting
to explore the world
from his situation in some
little village in South Sudan.
So whatever message I would
impart to you guys, it's that.
It's just, try to remember.
It's hard.
We're all caught up
in our own things.
That's how human beings are.
But just try to remember
there's another world out there.
And the more we're connected
and empathic with that,
the happier we'll be
as people, and the more
help we'll be giving.
And so in the book I
wrote, just to plug my book
and then we'll go to questions,
I just talk about this.
I talk about why I
really care about Africa,
what I've learned from it,
and if anything, just how it's
helped me be a better person.
A big part of my book
is a moral journey.
As a college kid, I did
a lot of stupid things.
I hurt people.
I made mistakes that I regret.
It took me a long time to learn
how to be a better person.
And I get a lot of that from
living in a part of the world
where I think people have
better values in many ways,
despite all this I've
said about conflict.
A lot of that is just coming
from a few people at the top,
and it's making many suffer,
but people are more connected.
And it's like that's what we're
doing with this technology.
We're bringing the world
more into closer contact
with each other.
So that's my spiel.
I appreciate you guys
giving me some of your time,
and I would love just to take
a few questions about my book,
or myself, or this part
of the world, anything.
Fire away.
You can hold the applause.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned bad
governance several times,
right?
But I guess they're not equal.
Out of these countries, where
do you see the most hope?
For example, I went
to Tanzania on safari,
thinking that it's one of
the better run countries
and the concept of
family and ujumaa.
So I mean, what are
some good examples
of some good governance there?
Or which is better out
of those countries there?
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN: Where
were you in Tanzania?
AUDIENCE: I went on
safari so I did the usual.
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN:
Serengeti and Goro Goro.
AUDIENCE: And Tarangire.
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN:
When was this?
AUDIENCE: This is 10 years ago.
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN: 10 years ago?
OK.
So it's changed a lot.
Tanzania is an
interesting example,
because there is
harmony in Tanzania.
Which there is not in
many African countries.
There's a sense of national
identity in Tanzania, which
there is not in many countries.
But Tanzania is really poor,
and Tanzania will always
be behind Kenya and some
of the other countries
in that region because of
its history of socialism.
And some of it failed really
bad, like these forced forms
and things.
It was kind of like
the Great Leap Forward.
But they got some things right.
And their governance-- so their
economic policy was really bad.
But they got some political and
social issues absolutely right.
And that was, "let's think
of ourselves as Tanzanian.
For better or for worse, we're
stuck in the same space that's
called Tanzania."
We can complain
about colonialism.
We can look back and
say, "you know what?
It makes no sense that that
Maasai 50 yards away from me
is a Kenyan and
we are Tanzanian."
Because those lines went
right through ethnic areas.
But that's the way it goes.
And the African Union
actually made a decision
in the '60s, when
it started, not
to revisit colonial borders.
Because it would be
this endless problem.
There would be disputes
all over the continent,
because none of those
borders make sense.
So the Tanzanians
did something smart.
The first president,
Julius Nyerere.
And he said, "we're Tanzanian.
Everybody's gotta
speak Swahili."
No local language.
You've gotta to speak Swahili.
And to enforce that, they did
it was almost like desegregation
busing.
They took kids from
Western Tanzania
and they sent them to Eastern
Tanzania for high school,
or from the north to the south.
They mixed mix
people up, so there
was no way to just get
comfortable in your area
and only speak your
local language.
And to this day, like I
studied Swahili in college,
and in Tanzania, it's
beautiful Swahili.
That's their national language.
And that permeated more than
just a linguistic issue.
It resulted in more
social cohesion.
And Tanzania has no history--
it's one of the few countries
in Africa--
literally, there's
very, very few
out of all those 54
countries with no history
of ethnic conflict.
So that's an example of
some very good governance,
but they did disastrous
economic policy,
where they said everybody should
live on these collective farms
and work together.
And the productivity went
down, and people starved.
It was just all that we
know from history shows that
doesn't work.
I think Tanzania is one
of the signs of hope,
because that cohesion
and stability is there.
I don't think anything
is going to shake that up
in the near term.
Kenya's very hopeful too.
It's just messy, politically.
It's very ethnic.
I can look at somebody's
ID, see their name,
and have a 90%
chance of guessing
who they're going to vote for.
Because I can tell their
tribe by their name, and I'll
know who they're
going to vote for.
Because people vote,
like almost everybody
in that country except a
few urban intellectuals,
will vote for the
person of their tribe.
And that results in all this
kind of crappy politics.
Because if you have a corrupt
leader, a corrupt politician,
and he's from your
ethnic group, you're
going to vote for him,
because he's your guy.
And so these guys
get away with murder.
Like, the salaries
in Kenya, this
is a really interesting fact.
The MPs, the members
of parliament in Kenya,
make something like
$200,000 a year.
So in absolute terms, they
are some of the highest paid
lawmakers in the world.
If you compare it relative to
the per capita national income,
average income, it would
be like a congressman
making like $20 million a year.
Because the average income
in Kenya is like $800.
These guys make $200,000.
If you look at the
American average income
and then project it
out by the same factor,
it would be like a congressman
making $40 million a year.
They keep getting elected.
People vote for these guys.
They give themselves raises.
It's all because of
the ethnic politics.
So some of that has deep roots.
It was the way these
countries were created.
They're young.
Most of the countries in Africa
are less than 60 years old.
America was a mess 60 years in.
That's when brother was killing
brother in the US civil war.
So you gotta keep that in mind.
It's not an excuse, but
it brings up this issue
of what's the yardstick.
Do we hold them to the same
standards as our countries?
Or do we hold them to their
own relative standards?
Or something in between?
Because you don't want
to get to relative.
Like, what's happened
in South Sudan
with people
slaughtering each other
is absolutely
wrong in all cases.
So I think governance is key.
And then there
are a few examples
of good central planning
but repressive governments.
So like Rwanda, very
good poverty programs,
very good development programs.
Rwanda is this tiny little
country packed with people.
It's one of the most
densely populated countries
in the world.
And that's a problem.
And so they've got to be really
smart how they use their land,
where they put their roads,
everything, family planning.
And they're doing
it, but there's
almost no freedom in Rwanda.
If you have a difference of
opinion, you're thrown in jail
or killed.
And so that's the choice
a lot of Africans have.
It's not even a choice.
That's the two alternatives
that they face.
It's either a really shitty
kind of crazy government that
doesn't care about you,
but you have some freedom,
or a government that's not
bad about improving your water
or giving your kids school
or a road that you can use,
but you have no freedom.
Not a great choice.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: Two parts.
You mentioned several times
about making the difference
and actually seeing it
over the course of 11 years
from when you first
got there till now.
Do you actually
see the difference?
I know from your articles,
looking at it from a job
perspective, that
you live there,
you have children
there, how has that
changed involved with--
especially with two kids.
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN: No,
it's a good question.
So things are different.
Things are better in
the most urban areas.
For instance, when I
got there 10 years ago,
we had dial up internet.
This was not that long ago.
I had dial up internet,
very slow speeds.
So we had to get
a satellite dish
and pay like $2,000 a month
for medium speed internet.
About five years ago
or four years ago,
a fiber optic line
finally was brought
to East Africa from Dubai.
Finally, they wired
the East African coast.
Internet speed is
now really good.
And that catalyzes a
lot of different stuff.
You start getting
better services.
There's online businesses.
You can get tickets online.
It just changes your
life, like it would here.
Infrastructure is
getting better.
The roads are getting better.
The airports are getting better.
The middle class is growing.
So you have more Kenyans--
I use this example.
So I left this out, but those
of you who have been there,
this will sound familiar.
Crime is a problem.
So living in Nairobi
in a nice house,
we have guards that
sit on our porch
every night with billy clubs and
a panic button, where they have
a necklace that they
press this button,
and then that will
alert a security company
to come and back them up.
That's just a feature of life.
That's one of the downsides.
There are these great
disparities of wealth,
and there's a lot
of poor people.
And it tends not to be super
hardcore violent crime,
but there's still home
invasions and carjackings.
But it's usually not gratuitous.
So we have these guards
that sit on our porch.
10 years ago, when
I moved to Kenya,
their phones would never ring.
I'd never hear them
talking on their phones.
Now I hear these guys
talking all the time
on their cell phones.
They're getting calls
from their villages,
they're talking to their wives.
That little improvement in
their disposable income,
their salaries have gone
up, the cell phone costs
have gone down.
They might not be
quite middle class,
but they're gainfully employed.
Their lives are getting
a little better.
They now have enough money to
talk to their people back home.
So that stuff, the
development is happening.
You're seeing it.
Sometimes, we're like exporting
the wrong stuff, I would say.
You know, there's
Domino's Pizza.
There's Burger King.
There's Coldstone Creamery.
You know, this kind of like
high cal, unhealthy food.
Kenyans actually eat pretty--
everything there
is very natural,
because like fast food
hasn't, up until recently,
been a phenomenon.
So if you go to a Kenyan
restaurant, you order a burger
and fries, it's going
take a half an hour.
But there's somebody
peeling the potato.
It's going to be fresh.
When you do get it,
it tastes really good
because it's made fresh.
So some of that's going away.
It's like Americans are
trying to eat more healthy.
Like red meat.
I'm doing a story
about land issues,
because Africa's population
is growing very fast.
And Africans rely on land.
And there's going to be these
pressures on too many people,
too little land.
And so I was looking at
beef stats, because beef--
I'm not like a hardcore--
I eat beef, but a
lot of vegetarians
will go on and on about the
resources that are needed
to feed a beef cow, right?
So the US and Europe,
they're decreasing the amount
of red meat that we eat.
Mostly for health reasons,
but other reasons.
In Kenya, people now
have enough money
to eat red meat,
which is a luxury.
And so there's more
herds, there's more cows,
and they need more space.
And that's creating
all these other issues.
So development brings
these complications,
but overall, lifespans
are getting longer,
kids are healthier, more
people are being educated,
they have more
access to technology.
In the urban areas, that's true.
But at the same time,
you have these places
like South Sudan, or Congo,
or Somalia that I cover.
And they're stuck.
They're not much
different from how
they were 10, 15, 20 years ago.
And those factors about bad
governance and conflict, that's
still embedded in these places.
So there's no quick solution.
All the leadership in South
Sudan is has been tainted.
That's putting it politely.
They're all really bad.
They're all pretty
brutal and corrupt.
All of them.
So you're going to need
another generation or two
for these guys to fade
out before you have
any hope of better leadership.
And then one thing I'll
bring up because we just
have a few more minutes,
wildlife is a big issue.
Because as these
populations grow,
people need more space for
farms, for roads, for housing.
And what you're seeing right now
is this onslaught on elephants,
on rhinos, on
natural environments,
where these animals live.
Sometimes, it's intentional.
There are people that are going
out and poaching elephants,
because the ivory, there's a
demand in China especially,
but in other Asian
countries, for ivory.
And that's pushing up the
price of elephant tusks.
And so you get these
poor guys in Kenya
that maybe make $100 a
month, if that, $50 a month.
And they can make
thousands of dollars
by killing one elephant.
And that's hard
economics to overcome.
So right now as
we speak, there's
been more elephants killed
in the last 10 years
than a higher proportion
of the elephant population
than ever before.
And it's scary.
Because it's a finite--
there's a few 100,000
elephants left.
That's it.
And they only live in
these big, wild spaces.
That's the direct threat.
The indirect threat
is just development.
I see it in Nairobi.
The city is growing
into these areas that
used to be rural or the bush.
And now they have
housing neighborhoods
on them, subdivisions.
And there used to be wild
animals there, or farms.
And so there's going to be
some problems with that.
And they're hard
choices to make.
You have a growing population.
You need to feed people.
Do you set aside land
that could be farmed
and say "no, you're not
allowed to farm that.
That's where elephants live."
Or do you just kick
off all the elephants,
or kill them off, and then say
we need to use that for a farm.
Those are hard questions.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: It's about Al-Shabab.
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Seems like the peak
was the Westgate terrorist act,
and from then it
glimpses, but I actually
am not current on where
they are right now.
I know they're shutting down--
but there's talk about shutting
down Dadaab, the refugee camp--
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN: Right.
No, no.
That's a good-- let me knock
on wood as I answer this,
because they've been down.
They've been down over
the last couple of years,
but they were down
before Westgate,
which was what was scary.
So the Westgate Mall
was a big mall in Kenya.
In 2013, these four
guys came in there,
part of an Islamic group,
and they just started machine
gunning shoppers and civilians.
And then they took over
them all for a few hours
until they were kicked out and
about 100 people were killed.
Kids, shoppers, just ordinary
people, terrorist attack.
They had been quiet before that.
And everybody was
saying, "oh yeah,
what happened the Shabab?"
And all of a sudden,
boom, one of the worst
terrorist incidents in
recent memory anywhere.
They're under a lot of pressure.
The US has done a
good job of killing
the leaders with drone
strikes and air strikes.
They've struggled for years
to get good intelligence,
and they now seem to have
it, because they're hitting--
they're killing the leaders.
But it's a big group.
Somalia has really
bad governance,
and is just an open space
where you can do anything.
So they're still there.
My guess is, they're
on the decline,
but they're capable of
doing some more nasty stuff.
And it's just kind of
a miracle that they
haven't attacked a big
Western target or an embassy.
Because that's who
they really don't--
that's who they're fighting.
The US is killing the leaders.
Why aren't they trying
to kill Americans?
They probably are.
It's just harder because the
American embassy in Nairobi
is a fortress.
So that's not an easy target.
The mall is a much
better target.
Dadaab, they've cooled off
on trying to close that.
The Kenyan government
really wanted to close that,
and they have been
sort of smacked back.
And their own courts
said, "no, it's
illegal to kick these guys out
because you've recognized them
as refugees."
And all the donors
who pay for Dadaab
are like, "we're not
giving you a cent
to relocate these people."
So they could do it.
Physically, they
could go in there
and push people out at gunpoint.
But they would
take so much crap,
and even their own courts
have said that's illegal.
So I don't think
that's going to change.
I think those people
are stuck there.
There's three generations now.
There's people that are--
there's grandchildren,
people that
came there as really
little kids, then had kids,
and then those kids had kids.
It's permanent.
And--
SPEAKER: We have time for one
more question, which I'll ask.
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN: Please.
SPEAKER: So there are
obviously many ups and downs
to being a journalist.
You were once a
young journalist,
aspiring journalist.
What advice would you have
given your younger self?
What do you know now that you
wish you'd known back then?
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN: God,
that's why I wrote that book.
And nobody is allowed to
leave here without the book,
because it's free.
I wish I had balanced
things better.
I wish I had not put so
much pressure on myself
to succeed professionally
that I made bad decisions
for my personal life.
Because when you're
young, you're torn.
Part of you is just desperate
to prove yourself and show
that you can be successful
and do something of value.
But another part
of you just wants
to have fun and get
close to people.
And before you have kids,
you have this opportunity
to enjoy the world
with somebody.
And that's a special time.
As you go on in life,
it's harder and harder
to have that opportunity
to just fall in love
and honor that love.
And so I think as
a young person,
I was like probably a lot
of people in this room.
I was really driven
professionally,
and I put a lot of
pressure on myself.
And I should have just
chilled out and been like,
"it'll work out."
And I should have honored my
personal side of my life more.
Because you don't
get that time back.
You're only like
20 or 25 like once.
And then it's done.
And so just to
keep that balance.
But it would have been hard.
You know what I mean?
I had to make a
lot of sacrifices
for my job to be standing
here talking to you guys,
some of those sacrifices
were probably necessary.
But I think I could have had
a little more perspective.
And I didn't.
I was really singularly focused.
SPEAKER: Well, that's all
we have time for today,
but thank you so
much for joining us.
Stick around for a
copy of the book,
and give him a big
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFFREY GETTLEMAN: Thanks, guys.